Speaker 1: Kentucky has now essentially banned
abortion in the state.
This is almost certainly a violation of Roe
v. Wade, but the Supreme Court is going to
rule in what is at this point only weeks,
whether Roe v. Wade is essentially gone.
And that's the really scary part of this Vox
reporting it is now practically impossible
to get an abortion in Kentucky.
A new law is forcing the state's last remaining
abortion providers to shut down Vox, reporting
Kentucky ended virtually all in-state abortions
Wednesday, enacting a sweeping law that bans
abortions after 15 weeks of pregnancy restricts
minors access to the procedure and cracks
down on medication abortions.
It's now the state with the harshest abortion
restrictions in the United States.
The new law goes into effect immediately.
It will force the state's two remaining abortion
clinics in Louisville to close due to onerous
new requirements on doctors, forcing Kentuckians
to look elsewhere for abortion care.
So again, this almost certainly violates Roe
v Wade.
Roe v. Wade says that the Constitution protects
women's liberty to choose to have an abortion
without excessive government restriction.
Now, excessive government restriction is the
source of much controversy and opens itself
up to significant interpretation.
So excessive restriction allows some restriction,
but not too much.
And under Roe v. Wade closing, putting such
onerous requirements on abortion providers
such that they all close would without a doubt
in any sensible interpretation of Roe v. Wade,
be considered to be unconstitutional.
That's onerous if the if the requirements
are so strict that every provider in the state
closes and people seeking an abortion have
to go to a different state.
That would violate Roe v. Wade by any sensible
interpretation.
But this will be appealed, of course.
But in so in that process, during that process,
the Supreme Court might decide in June we
are going to effectively overturn Roe v. Wade
by allowing extremely harsh state laws to
stand.
Roe v. Wade could be gone in a few weeks and
as is often the case in red states that are
trying to ban abortion.
Many of those states are an economic and educational
and health care disaster.
I've said this so many times before the states
that are obsessed with these cultural issues
are disastrous states.
By almost every metric, if you look at Kentucky,
for example, Kentucky is 43 out of 50 in terms
of health care.
Kentucky is 40th out of 50 in terms of its
economy.
Kentucky is 48th out of 50 in fiscal stability,
44th in education and 47th in terms of poverty
rate.
And yet their focus is let's try to ban abortion.
We've talked before at minimum, at minimum,
if you want to ban abortion, you should include
all sorts of support for the expectant mothers
and parents because all of these additional
children being born that folks in theory wanted
to not have born.
So you're going to give them financial support,
right?
Well, no, no, no.
That's not right, either.
And this all ties back.
I haven't used I used to talk about this a
lot.
I haven't for some period of time.
This is what's called strict father morality.
You know, the strict dad who says, Well, it's
the principle, it's the principle.
They want to control women's bodies.
They have a religious view on, you know, sexual
intercourse is supposed to be strictly for
procreation.
And they're against comprehensive sex education.
And often they're against contraception.
So so that doesn't always.
But you don't want abortion, but you also
don't want to do the things to prevent unintended
pregnancy.
What do you want?
And they say, Well, we want procreative sex
in the context of marriage.
And anything outside of that means one needs
to suffer the consequences.
That's the right morality.
If you get pregnant, you've got to have the
kid and you've got to deal with paying for
all of the expenses of the kid as well.
Wait, but so it doesn't make sense, because
we know that one of the best ways to prevent
unwanted pregnancy is total and complete access
to contraception.
Comprehensive sex education.
That's how you prevent unwanted pregnancy.
Excellent study out of St. Louis looked at
this.
Oh no, but that wouldn't be the right morality,
because that would open the door to people
just having sex.
And that no, no, no.
That doesn't go with our morality.
It's completely backwards.
It is antiquated thinking it is non-science
thinking.
But horrifyingly and particularly if the Supreme
Court decision at the end of June effectively
reverses Roe v. Wade, this is going to be
the law of the land in many, many red states.
Now, as I've said before, what should the
people in these states do?
Because on the one hand, one approach would
be, well, we need progressives and center
left Democrats and whatever to move to these
states to change the laws by becoming involved
in local government.
Yeah, but that's a big uphill battle.
It's almost easier to say to the folks who
are rational and clear thinking leave those
states and go to a blue state.
But the problem is, a lot of people can't
afford to do that.
So it really is a disastrous situation.
I don't know what the abortion landscape is
going to look like, say, 12 months from now.
A big piece of that is because we don't know
what the Supreme Court will decide in a few
weeks.
And another part of that is we don't know
to what degree red states will continue pushing
these types of laws.
Every indication is that red states are determined
to push this stuff.
Another reason yet as if we needed more reasons,
yet another reason why the upcoming midterm
elections are so consequential.
And by that, I mean, it's not just about who
we elect to the U.S. Senate and the U.S. House
of Representatives, but there are tons of
local elections as well that are going to
set the tone.
Governors races, state senates state houses
of representatives.
We will talk about it more.
We'll talk about what's at stake, but it is
a very, very big deal.
We'll have more on this on our Instagram.
You can find The David Pakman Show on Instagram
by searching The David Pakman Show on Instagram.